we dug in the et vault we found
something from 2003 that you're gonna
love my voice is gonna be higher now
Heidi Adam Brody here thanks for coming
and taking a peek into my life I feel
like you're gonna find it's really
unglamorous
and just a regular jeans and a t-shirt
kind of get out but uh it'll be fun and
hopefully you won't be too unimpressed
so thanks let me show you around okay
I'll call you girls later all right
no ordinarily this would be about the
time that I would have what we like to
call breakfast but I'm an actor so we're
not allowed to eat that's the best work
I've done
weinerman and perform the ritual we're
all dead founder I mean blood marriage
family drama you're giving us everything
and ready or not why are you so excited
for fans to see this amazing movie it's
just such a good time it's a good time
it's like a 90-minute roller coaster
it's um it's like a classic or comedy
it's a classic date night movie I don't
know you give us that signature Adam
Brody comedic chops that keeps us
laughing I mean I'm terrified but I'm
also laughing it was so good we saw it
oh good good cool you know fans at these
are Rachel last week we're dying for an
OC reboot did you guys talk about it we
we did it we talked about rebooting
friends maybe we're thinking about
getting that going but no we didn't talk
about a reboot let's talk about all
times what would it take so much money
so much I don't know I don't know are
you watching me Sean the hills I saw an
episode and it's good
like my kids would you make an
appearance again I go back to the money
you know